foreign
I have a I have a bone to pick with you
and it involves an article that I
received and I want to get your take on
it because Rachel Cruz and I have
covered this issue on Smart money happy
hour and it went gangbusters and it's
all about phones to pick with music I
did something because I feel like you're
gonna you're gonna try to be a hero on
this one
that's my thing let's do it let's do it
so we did an episode called guilt
tipping how to deal with an absurd
tipping culture and it was the tip of
the iceberg because now John according
to Wall Street Journal tipping Has Come
For self-serve checkout
so you and the Machine in the machine
says money please
this is wild so prompts to leave twenty
percent of self-checkout machines at
airport stadiums cookie shops cafes
across the country are rankling
consumers already inundated by the
proliferation of tip screens how many
ten dollar words could this author fit
in here it is the Wall Street Journal
and here's the crazy part business
owners say the odd the automated cues
can significantly increase gratuities
and boost staff pay
you know what else could boost staff pay
paying them more not cheap uh bosses and
leaders
oh man and here's a quote from a senior
at American University in DC they're
cutting labor costs by doing
self-checkout so what's the point of
asking for a tip and where is it going
and tipping researchers didn't know that
was a job and labor Advocates say
so-called tip creep is a way for
employers to put the onus for the
employee to pay on to Consumers rather
than raising wages themselves companies
say tips are an optional thanks for a
job well done
this is exhausting yeah
um
so as you were talking I I man I went
from hemorrhoids to I think I've got
like some kind of lung disorder oh no
yeah my body's falling apart as I listen
to this dysentery there's two parts to
this George one is
I love I love what it says here it says
that the businesses are taking advantage
of an opportunity they are
that's what businesses do they take
advantage of opportunities right they
see a glitch in The Matrix and they're
like hey let's make some money fine
I think it is unethical
to
put the onus of paying your employees on
the
in addition to the the product or
service that somebody's just purchased
to put that on the the purchaser that's
insane be a grown-up and pay your
employees what they're worth if you
think they've done a job well done pay
them for it don't be like well I don't
know man the second thing is is I don't
lose a second of sleep over this crap
because I they can do whatever they want
it's on me and we have a culture that is
so sad when somebody makes them feel a
certain way they're making me feel sad
at the kiosk well then that's on you
dude if the kiosk that you have gone and
got your own water and put it on a
self-checkout and it asks you for a tip
and that makes you sad that's not the
business's fault that's your fault you
need to go to counseling and get friends
and also don't tweet about it just don't
do it and if you stop doing it it will
go away we have a culture it's so easy
if you don't tweet about it did it even
happen
I don't see that's just bad philosophy
right but I I I'm just not going to lose
a second asleep you're gonna love this
description a 26 year old who works in
PR New York City said the prompt in
general is a bit of emotional blackmail
oh my gosh now for sure this section
this this this segment is brought to you
by Preparation H because I have Atomic
hemorrhoids now it is not emotional
blackmail it's a business trying to get
more money from you all you have to do
uh 26 year old who works in public
relations in New York City is be an
adult hey jumping in John do you how do
you feel about with people when a person
turns the screen around and then they
ask for a tip is that feel more
emotional it it does it's awkward it's
awkward it doesn't make me feel like
emotional blackmail it just feels
awkward because I'm not giving you 38
tip right now if it's like my barber or
something that's fine but I yes if I
have to look at some 17 year old and
have this exchange like I'm sorry that
your boss doesn't pay you very well and
they're trying to guilt me into giving
you more or just to make automate me
giving you more fine but I don't feel
guilty about it it's not emotional
blackmail is it awkward yeah it can be
awkward but I'm gonna do what I think is
right in the situation and move on by
the way underground one of the biggest
disagreements my wife and I have is I
over tips I'm always over tipping what
this is doing for me is it's making me
Recon the other way correct well I don't
think that Force gratuity is any kind of
General opportunity it's not generosity
it's not gratuity it's a cost right so
either raise the cost of your chicken
sandwich by 25 cents or
uh and pay your employees what they're
actually Worth or um move on yeah well I
have no shame I go to the custom tip
amount and I do 0.00 enter while making
direct eye contact it's a flex John it's
a flex it is kind of I can't stand like
turn around they go it's just gonna ask
you a few questions like you don't know
what the questions are exactly you know
good and well James does that make you
feel sad and uncomfortable James is I'm
glad you brought up the question thing
because it is they act like like they
don't know what questions
we don't know right exactly that's like
um calling your wife and saying hey I'm
gonna be four hours late getting home
for our date and she'll be like I'll
have a few questions for you when you
get home and you're driving like I
wonder what they are you know what they
are you know what they are oh thank you
for that is exactly how I thought it
would go John poorly thank you that was
fun so why did you think I was trying to
be a hero because last time we did this
you're like I always over tip which
again you use that line I do but I don't
do it on demand I do it because I don't
want to be a person of uh like
generosity when when it becomes a demand
or when it comes like a it loses the joy
dude that's good becomes a payment and
I'm not gonna buy a 40 chicken sandwich
we're not falling for it we're hitting
zero